technology is no longer something that's
just restricted to large companies or
large countries or even rich countries
so everywhere on the planet and now as
access you know it is there's the
potential to have access to technology
people in developing economies often own
smartphones and technologies that
equivalent rates to people in the
developed world I'd felt quite often
they'll have that before they even have
sanitation in some cases so the
pervasive nature of technology is one of
the most important features of it the
other important feature is just a rate
and pace enriched adoption is actually
occurring just to put some comparative
numbers on this if you think about
television it took something like 38
years before television penetration got
to the first 50 million people it took
Twitter nine months so just the rate and
acceleration which adoption occurs is
pretty phenomenal and then the other
feature that becomes very interesting
about technology is not just its pace
and scale and the rate of innovation but
the economic aspects of Technology so
when you have things in digital form
that actually the profound impact on how
it affects the economics of things so
digital technologies have this feature
that have that you know economists think
of it as the non-rivalry and then
excludability of it what that means is
that my use of something that's in
digital form doesn't necessarily as a
physical technological matter preclude
your use of it the good news about that
is that from a user standpoint this is
all good because it's what economists
talk about is consumer surplus so the
fact that it doesn't cost us that much
more to get access to information with
its educational material entertainment
material that's all good for us is as
consumers I think it puts new challenges
for companies because now you have to
think about how do you generate revenues
and monetize this we've seen how
technology is caused you know with these
marginal cost economics disruptions in
many many many many industries whether
it's the media world's the entertainment
world that so it has these
disruptive effects but for users it's
generally good in the sense that it's
all you know useful information that you
get the investments in in technology
infrastructure and technology assets is
now pervasive across every sector with
its we're talking healthcare or we're
talking the public sector or talking
about education or talk about industrial
in fact one of the more exciting things
about in the industrial area arena is
what everybody now refers to as the
Internet of Things that for the first
time we're now going to be connecting
machines sensors physical things of any
sort that we like I think that's gonna
have a huge and profound impact so think
about all the machine-to-machine
communications interactions think about
the possibility for how we manage our
use of energy how we manage our homes
how we manage these settings with us the
workspace the home the car when machines
and things get in that get connected
what I find interesting about that in
particular is what that does to
questions about industry structure and
competition I think we always used to
imagine that you know companies would
compete within their sectors so this
idea of these you know sectors made
sense at some point but when you have
technology and technology-based assets I
think it becomes possible to enter many
many sectors on the base of technology
platforms think about the fact that now
we're talking about Amazon as a
computing company through their cloud
services think about the fact that you
now have Alibaba applying for banking
licenses think about the fact that some
of the most profound innovations and
transportations are being done by
technology Internet companies Google and
others so I think when you know one of
the things that happens the technology
makes it possible for participants in
competition to come from often outside
the sector so that's one big change to
industry structure another big change
industry structure is on the K on the
question of what it takes to compete so
you're now going to see many many small
companies be able to have kind of the
power and the ax
and the potential to disrupt sectors
that historically you have associated
with just large companies so this idea
of competition coming from outside the
sector outside the geography and very
often from my smaller companies I think
it's gonna have a profound impact on the
structure of industries in the economy